hey what's up instagram live it's girls
five ezza and we're here with a surprise
first look at us
the eyeball icon thing is saying zero
it's just us in here it's just us in
here
oh cease and desist [ __ ]
girls five eva are hoping to become two
hit wonders
we are officially in album mode
finally we're in charge of the fetch no
more singing whatever crap they give us
half our old songs weren't even spell
checked we don't want no average
we're back in biz
need the album done in six weeks
that that's fast i know people over 30
tend to have other things in their lives
i have a kid
but she never talks to me so i'm via
veil okay girls five eva
you're a producer we got another toxic
dude on our hands coco i don't think i
saw him sniff our chair he didn't did he
take his deck out not that i would
notice they are so boring to me
[Music]
we just have to make the most undeniable
album of all time what you got there
rick my riff rolodex all the greats are
in here
our album drops in a month we need to
make noise now you're shooting a music
video how often should my mouth be in a
shot like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
can't lose let's hit it
you wrote all of the songs on the album
so if everybody hates it it means that
they hate you as a person on every level
jesus summer what oh
[Music]
got
no
you